thank you
today
so wrong
thank you
again
hi everybody
welcome to the Joint launch of this
amazing book uh co-edited by Mila and
UNESCO on the missing links on AI
governance I'm Ludovic devices
[Music]
so the first part the opening remarks of
this event will be mostly in French
the
[Music]
neural magnet positions
foreign
you'll have a 15-minute question period
for the people in the crowd and uh you
will have two media opportunities for
the media opportunities
[Music]
so the journalists will have two
opportunities one uh after the opening
remarks and one after the uh question
period by the people in the in the in
the room uh
[Music]
foreign
services
relief
wow
good morning everyone
um
on my behalf on behalf of Professor
Benjo and of all of our colleagues at
Mila welcome thank you for being here
this morning for this exceptionally Rich
interesting and important event a very
special thanks to Professor or Dr Kate
Crawford thank you so much Kate for
accepting our invitation for being a
part of this thank you to UNESCO for
your trust your partnership and thank
you thank you thank you to all the
authors and co-authors of this book
missing links in AI governance
today's event is about Big Ideas
uh big mines or
um great minds all of this at a very
pivotal time uh in our history in the
history of mankind I think we can all
agree just by scanning through the
newspapers that AI well the potential of
it has always been there and you know
for the last couple of years with all
kinds of ups and downs right now it's
one of the foremost conversations for
all of us in all spheres of our lives
and Society
today's event has two uh two Dimensions
to it on one hand we're launching a book
A book that results from a historic
collaborations
historic collaboration between UNESCO
and Mila that brings forward the latest
most provocative most relevant thought
leadership about AI governance I was
talking to my colleague earlier and he
said in the spirit of the book we really
wanted to push boundaries not say what
everyone was saying already but say
something new say something different
try to think about where we were going
next
and of course
it's an incredible privilege to host
today a conversation between two of the
world's top most leaders in AI but also
two of the strongest advocates for it
being developed in a medical socially
responsible and sustainable way so if
you think that part of the event is
going to be you know stuff you've heard
of before hopefully not because just in
the couple of minutes when you know we
were getting gathered there was already
a lot of appetite and energy to say okay
what are we going to do about this is
throughout the book and certainly
throughout our conversation today you're
gonna see we talk about topics like
feminism indigenous rights lb LG bti
people deep fakes autonomous weapons
sdgs pandemics
topics we can all agree are among the
biggest challenges and opportunities of
our society of us at this moment in
history and even more so within the
context of everything that's happened in
the last few months where there's this
increased urgency to look at and try to
answer some of the questions addressed
in the book namely around how this
technology is going to serve the
potential and the future of human life
on Earth so as you can see this is
something that holds that we hold very
dear to heart for me personally and for
all of us at Mila
conversations
enjoy this should be fun
don't
know
security
services
UNESCO
diet is
foreign
responsibility
zombies
[Music]
foreign
missing links in AI governance
possible
[Music]
Generations
applications
objective the development
a formation
potential significative
complexity Islam
occupations
Mila
is
ladies and gentlemen
as we launch this publication it is
important to emphasize that the
development and governance of AI require
careful consideration and responsible
decision making especially in areas of
missing links
it is crucial that policy makers and
Civil Society members are equipped with
the necessary insights and perspectives
to ensure that the development of AI is
Guided by fundamental rights and
freedoms and is ethical and responsible
while this publication provides valuable
insights into various aspects of AI
governance we also recognize the need
for more accessible and concise
information for decision makers
therefore we are seeking funding to
produce policy briefs or relevant topics
to supplement this publication
the establishment of trustworthy and
responsible AI is an essential step
towards creating inclusive and peaceful
societies
we hope that this publication will spark
important discussions
and raise critical questions to ensure
that AI benefits everyone
and leaves no one behind
we are grateful to the authors to Mila
to the government of Quebec and to our
colleagues for their invaluable
contributions to this publication
I look forward to listening to today's
conversation between professor joshia
benzio and Professor Kate Crawford
two world-class experts on AI
I also look forward to engaging with you
in the future on the important topic of
AI governors
I wish you an inspiring reading of this
report and a fruitful discussion during
today's event
thank you for your credit attention
is
to
foreign
usual
along that is
responsible
applications
foreign
Francaise
de mobilizations
artificial
is
Mercedes
[Music]
foreign
thank you
um
foreign
[Music]
programmer
civil
community
assistant
it's been a journey but it's also been
quite the thrill
um
[Music]
large
message
and last but not least the Kate Nashua
for for showing up today
um you are of course as I'm sure
everywhere you're going but you're of
course two very very Stellar members of
this book
um and I think your engagement coming up
on this stage and talking about this
outside just the academic world is is
really it's impressive
um it's something we're very grateful
for certainly something I'm very
interested in hearing as well
and so I would stop and then and give it
to Girls by leaving you on Three core
insights that in my View kind of come
out of this book as a whole
the first one is a dire need for being
far more inclusive in the way we develop
AI
and that goes beyond representation so
of course it means having women at the
table and having indigenous communities
at the table and so on but it also means
being very thoughtful about how we
develop AI systems what kind of data we
use what kind of design we choose to go
for And So It Goes to representation but
it goes far beyond and it's it's frankly
just
it's an opportunity or a risk that we
really need to tackle
the second one is as I said earlier a
need for governmental and international
organizations leadership and businesses
can do their part
but the role of government in
international organizations are to make
sure that whatever happens in society
and this is one of the big very very big
things that's happening is is done in a
way that's collectively beneficial
and the third one is and it's I think a
great way of opening the conversation is
is one inviting people to stop looking
at AI as a neutral technology and rather
think about it as a place of power
and so that means asking who holds that
power and who doesn't who benefits from
that power and who's excluded from it
um and frankly it goes to the question
as to what are the structures that we
can provide ourselves because if with
great power crates becomes great
responsibility and so if we in this room
are the holders of that power then what
are the structures that we're going to
put forward to address it and to make
sure that we that we really Foster the
opportunities of AI and mitigate the
risks
so on this note
I Turn to You
um I'm also taking this opportunity to
welcome you to this event
um this book I started working with
Benjamin and um Catherine and UNESCO two
years ago and I couldn't be happier or
more proud that I'm here today at the
launch events of this book I'm very
proud of this book and as the name
suggests that we are talking about the
missing links missing links is that like
we have included the topics that you're
not really seeing
um that people are talking about it most
often but we believed that we should
talk about these things and we wanted to
give a spotlight to those Topics in this
book so this book I'm very proud of and
I think is very important topic and I I
want to encourage you to read about this
book because we included the topics of
like as Benjamin mentions like how AI
can
change the industry in a sense of the
povert it has influence on Education
Health Care it has an influence on
finance and economy so
this is our important topics that
everyone should care about them and this
book I'm I'm just encouraging you to
read about it and be this book be the
start of a discussion and not being
domestic links anymore and be the
spotlight topics
um I also take this opportunity to talk
about one of the the chapters of this
book that I contributed to which we
talked about
um the role of ethics and fairness in AI
industry the challenges the
opportunities and I conducted interviews
with seven researchers from industry and
Academia also activists the journalists
and I try to include the voice of people
who are known as being minorities so I
included the voice of women black people
from Asia from Africa from Europe from
North America to talk about like why it
is challenging to talk about ethics and
algorithmic fairness because AI industry
I think is like every industry nowadays
is
industry so talking about this aspects
is important because fairness is not
about like how like it's not technical
challenge it's a social technical
Challenge and it affects all of us right
we are as a customers as a developers
and we need to think about it
interesting thing is that I encourage
you to read that chapter I have seven
people that I interviewed with and two
of them that are working in industry in
North America they got laid off and both
of them were AI ethics leaders in
Industry so it is an important topic I
did that interview two years ago and I
think it's more important today to
discuss these topics so without further
Ado I I invite you to listen to Great
Joshua and Kate and they're going to
have a debate about it and uh enjoy the
events thank you so much
for the Medias we have a 15-minute
period right now with Benjamin for Adobe
the media Representatives want to wait
after uh the conversation uh so at the
end of the event after the question
period you will have another uh moment
for interviews
I know
Ed Crawford yeshu benjois installing
all right let's get to it guys
okay I'm going off script this tends to
happen but I was inspired by what all of
a lot of the people said in their
opening remarks so I want to start by
hearing each of you on why you care of
all the things you could be doing today
or in the course of the last few months
and of all the institutes with whom
UNESCO could have interacted like why
Yasha banjo why Mila why is this
important to you Yasha
um
I want to give meaning to my life I
think that's one of the best things
is about
doing research in AI
in the last
um
right so it was so nice you have to
start again I'm sorry
so I think uh
uh
important parts of being used is this
working now it should be working yeah
yeah all right okay just to use this uh
an important part of being human is is
um you know why are you doing what
you're doing and and
um and feeling good about what you do
and when you
think and act
to give back to help to contributes to
others in society I think this is a an
amazing uh there's any good feeling that
motivates a lot of people and a lot of
people at Mila and this is something
we've tried to put in minimize values
and I would need more of in society
um John Lennon
um so
I'm happy to share
is this working yeah thank you sorry
about that yes we can
yes so
um
yeah in in AI specifically since
2013 more or less
uh it's not anymore just an academic
question it's changing the world you
know it has been progressing every year
and and now we're all like amazed and
scared and I think forced to think
what do we do
okay it was a very bold decision on your
part to write a book that basically
criticizes from front to back cover this
industry that you participate in right
so the atlas of AI of course I'm
referencing two so why is this important
to you there you could feel throughout
the book and I've listened to a few of
your podcasts there's this energy to say
you know beyond the technology beyond
the science that of course both of you
have dedicated your lives to there needs
to be more tell us tell us a bit about
that
well first of all hi everyone it's
lovely to see you here and thank you so
much to Joshua and Valerie for inviting
me to join you for this very important
book launch
in terms of myself I started 20 years
ago researching how large-scale
Technologies are influencing the world
and as a social scientist 20 years ago
it was quite unusual to see this as
something that was important and
necessary to understand the full impacts
of these systems
and one of the things that has always
concerned me is that there is a tendency
particularly in AI to focus on the data
and the algorithms and sometimes the
infrastructure but that's it and this is
I think a very serious error that we do
not look at the large-scale material
impacts of these systems so what I
wanted to do for Atlas of AI is to
understand how AI is made and I mean
that in the fullest sense so I ended up
getting out from behind my desk and
going to visit the lithium mines going
to the clickworker factories going
inside distribution centers as well as
going to the labs where these systems
are made and what I saw was really A
system that is profoundly extractive by
Nature so you think about how training
sets are made it's really based on
capturing the commons of the internet
and using that to make ground truth and
then looking at the labor Dynamics
everything from Mine Workers through to
the experience of being a data labeler
this is throughout the supply chain of
AI but we rarely talk about the human
layer and then finally the full
environmental impacts of planetary scale
computation that means looking at energy
looking at water and looking at the
mineralogical components to make
large-scale servers in doing all of this
work
it completely transformed my thinking
and I thought it was important to share
that with a global reading audience to
say we are Building Systems where we are
not looking at the full impacts of the
bargains we are making and what was
clear to me also is that these are
systems that concentrate power and that
is something that Joshua and I have
spoken about for for several years now
but it has only become more significant
in the two years since the book was
published particularly now with
generative AI we're seeing fewer than
six companies produce generative AI at
scale that is one of the most
concentrated Industries in the world so
how are we going to deal with that and I
think it's the people in this room many
of you are going to be at the Forefront
of building these systems but also
thinking about their governance and
honestly I think it is the most
important thing we could be doing now
so let's get into this theme of power so
in the UNESCO book your contribution is
actually one of the chapters from the
atlas of AI it's about data and I'm
going to quote a sentence from it you
say the myth of data collection as the
benevolent practice in computer science
has obscured its operations of power
protecting those who profit most while
avoiding responsibility for its
consequences this is also a theme that
Yuval Harare explores in 21 lessons for
21st century that has inspired some of
the work we do here so let's get into
this AI the impact of the extraction to
create this industry and then what it's
creating as a polarized or an unbalanced
power dynamic in the world well I'm sure
many people in this room are aware of
the downsides of scraping the internet
and calling that ground truth of all of
the biases all of the skus all of the
flots of the Jetsam that supposedly
represents the world and regularly fails
to do so but I want to talk about
something else which is the newest shift
that we've seen particularly with
generative AI so what we're seeing now
is companies like open AI scraping the
creative work of not just decades but
centuries of artistic practice images
words code and then again in so many
ways ascribing that to their own systems
it will profit very few people so how do
we think about all of the labor that
went into all of those images all of
those books all of that code this is
something that at the moment we have no
system of recompense people have no
consent they have no credit and they
have no compensation now that is a
serious problem if we think about what
that data presents but there's actually
an optimistic way to think about this
which is to look to history so
historically there was another
transformative technology just as
powerful as generative AI that was
invented in 1897 and it was called the
player piano does anyone here know what
a player piano is yeah a couple of
people wonderful so you've probably seen
those wax cylinders that had little
imprinted code really of music that
allowed you to create an automated piano
so when these were first invented
musicians were horrified they said this
was going to automate the work of of
reading and playing music so what we saw
in fact was a significant regulatory
move in 1909 the US Congress passes the
Copyright Act that says we will create a
mechanical license that will allow you
to produce these cylinders to produce
mechanical music but you also have to
pay artists and that became the basis of
the modern music industry so I think we
have to look at these examples to say
how do we regulate what is happening
with data collection and AI so that we
recognize the important creative labor
that has made all of these systems
possible so part of what I think we can
also do as a tool here is to look to
history to say how have we dealt with
transformative General Technologies in
the past and what are we going to do now
because I think what we cannot do is
allow people to simply just be used as
raw material to just be have their labor
extracted and to never have the gains of
generative AI shared more generally
I just want to comment on this uh I feel
like we can't apply the same recipe
because it's not one author but it's
everyone so maybe a better way to think
about this is that all of that data that
humans are producing that is feeding you
into these large AI systems
is is really contributing to
a collective uh wealth and should be
treated as such
rather than
oh like the mining industries that exist
in different countries like here where
essentially it's free to use what's
under the ground
uh and then you can make profit of it
and and you know for a time it might
seem like a reasonable thing to
incentivize companies to do that
extraction but I think we've reached the
point both in mining hopefully before
and in AI where we have to think okay
but really this is something that
belongs to everyone
how do we make sure yes that technology
is developed it's developed for good and
somehow
the the wealth that is created goes back
to everyone and that's connected to of
course the question of concentration of
power because wealth and power are
closely connected
the chapter you contribute to in the
book Yeshua is called Innovation
ecosystems for socially beneficial Ai
and you said this a bit in your opening
remarks you do this work because you
fundamentally believe it can create a
better place for us all right in the
future the the quote I chose is as the
current lisifier approach in the AI
industry has demonstrated the market is
unlikely to develop socially beneficial
Technologies with the size and scope
that are needed to address some of the
most intractable or important Global
challenges from climate change to
education to health which is an area you
focused on I know one of your core
convictions is a bit of a redesign of
our social and political structures
right so the world has changed you need
to adapt the infrastructure that's
holding that world and social political
structures as part of that so tell us a
bit more about some of your thoughts on
that yeah so first of all
uh
uh I'm not a social scientist and you
know but at some point
a number of years ago I realized that
there's a way like there's a
mathematical way to think about society
and
um the economic systems we have
and it
you can think of the
existence first of all of a misalignment
between
what happens if you push towards profit
maximization what is what direction does
it want to go versus what is it
Direction you know that would be best
for society to improve the well-being of
everyone and ideally you know these two
things would coincide but they don't
so you can think these are like two
vectors and there's an angle between
them if it was 180 degrees it would be
easy we could just like you know get rid
of profit maximization but it's not that
simple because that that capitalist
system also brought a lot of uh good
things
so
first of all we need to recognize that
how this is being fixed right now is
with governments that are putting
regulation to try to steer you know uh
companies closer to the well-being of
everyone and okay I think it has worked
reasonably well and there are a lot of
problems and I think we need to continue
in that direction but I don't think it's
enough
because
we're building very powerful tools and
AI is one of them I think biotechnology
is as scary and has a huge
uh positive potential both of them have
a huge positive potential to save us
from things that we don't know how to
tackle like climate change future
pandemics uh and it has motivated a lot
of my own research and and a lot of
research at B-Line in many research
centers around the world including in
companies actually to develop AI tools
um that are more directly aligned with
the needs of society even if
they're you know not sufficiently
profitable for companies to invest in
so we need governments to do that uh
investment because it's going to help
everyone
but we also need to realize that as the
tools we're building become more and
more powerful
that way of dealing with the problem may
be insufficient that uh
[Music]
that we may be hitting into a wall and
the image I have
to think about this is Imagine That in a
few years from now maybe you know decade
from now
um AI has become so powerful that it's
it can be as destructive as
uh say nuclear bombs
so what if a few people
um have that power well first of all
there's the problem of power
concentration the more powerful the tool
the more powerful the weapon the the
more you can concentrate power you can
control others and so on
and that's a big danger for democracy
but also
uh somebody that's just crazy or stupid
can press on the button and bang uh we
all lose
so how do we how do we change society to
deal with those dangers uh this is this
is a huge question and it takes us to
the topic of international government
governance right so nation states have
work to do within their Frontiers within
their boundaries but the question of AI
or the potency of AI is global so what
are some of your emerging thoughts both
of you around
the potential the possibility is is this
even feasible
well I'm really glad Joshua that you
mentioned nuclear power and nuclear
efficient because again we have good
historical examples that we can go to
here so the nuclear energy commission is
an example of a an international
structure that was created to Monitor
and to inspect nuclear energy facilities
internationally and it was decided that
this capacity for power generation is so
dangerous and has such a such a
proximity to weaponization that it was
in the interests of International Peace
and governance that it should be managed
transparently and should be open to
inspection
we have done this in the past but we
don't have anything similar to this at
the moment what we have is a very small
number of privately held companies that
are motivated by in many cases either
shareholder profit or individual profit
that are not sharing what they're doing
we actually have a profoundly opaque
system I'm thinking now of course of
gpt4 of the recent paper that was
published just last week is a hundred
pages that tells us nothing about how it
is built what is the data that it's
using what is the algorithmic approach
it used to be better it used to be
better we had a good decade right of
Industry developing AI in a much more
open science way precisely but I'm
really concerned that we're going to
lose good part of that we share this
concern and and I think it has two
significant challenges built within it
the first is a scientific challenge I
think it is a problem for us as
scientists to not understand how
something is built particularly if it is
going to be then applied to health care
to education to criminal justice to
hiring this presents a very real social
threat if we cannot understand its
workings but it also presents a
governance challenge so we're of course
talking about both state level and
international governance
it is very hard to govern and regulate
something that you cannot see into
and so we actually have to start
thinking about what are the mechanisms
to say this requires inspection now of
course the argument that you'll hear
from companies is that these this is
essentially a question of commercial
competitive threat we have to keep it
secret it's a trade secret we can't tell
you how it works well we have many
Industries whereby even if you keep
commercial confidence you still have to
be open to inspection to regulation and
to auditing so we are looking I think
very closely to having to have something
similar in AI but I agree with you
Joshua I don't think it's entirely
enough I think we have a misalignment
between the sorts of incentivized
capitalist structures that drive the
creation of AI with these issues around
greater social benefit and actually
sharing social goods which you which you
began with and so I think it's a
question we have to ask ourselves if we
are really concerned about
this process of public inclusion and
public sharing of the wealth should
these actually be publicly held systems
are we looking at something where we
have to have some role of public
governance I'm curious what you think
um totally with you here
um I want to bring up
a discussion that is happening uh you
know among some AI scientists
uh
thinking about the example in physics of
discern
in Europe
where huge amounts of money were poured
in by governments
to advance a science that would help
everyone
so physics was really
crucial in 50s and 60s for for the
reasons of you know nuclear power for
example and and nuclear uh dangers
um but today I think AI is is one of
those Technologies and and the
underlying science
that needs
International coordination both on the
side of Regulation like we need to have
teeth
that are not just within our border
borders but globally and and countries
you know in the same way that we've done
for the nuclear issues need to
coordinate
uh to minimize potential damage and uh
and regulate and
bring much more transparency but there's
also the positive side we need to make
sure that that
the future progress is not owned by just
a couple of companies but actually
happens in directions that benefit
society and that's going to happen if
governments maybe create something like
a CERN of AI it doesn't have to be like
actually physically centralized like
like CERN is
um but but if we want to develop AI
that's going to help fight climate
change help with education and
healthcare for example
uh we're going to need to build these
large real Nets that require huge
amounts of capital but hopefully that's
going to be owned by us by society and
targeted towards these these uh these
benefits
as I listened to you talking especially
Kate U reference history so it's like oh
yeah we've done this before we can do it
again and I have to admit part of me is
like
there's no way government is going to
move fast enough not not at this speed
at which AI is moving the the difference
the progress between Chad GPT 3 and 4 is
is mind-boggling so so help me reconcile
this or confirm that my instinct is
right and that we're really at the
threshold of our Regulators our
governments influential people worldwide
needing to step up faster than we've
ever done before
or you've isolated the thing that keeps
me up at night which is we know how fast
this is moving now I don't know about
how you're feeling but I every week I'm
like Oh my another model another set of
things I need to research it's an
extraordinary pace and you know Joshua
and I were chatting backstage you know
neither of us expected that we would see
this level of progress this quickly and
while it's exciting for its potential
positive benefits it presents a genuine
challenge for Regulators who do not move
quickly by Design because they move
slowly in order to listen to their
constituents in order to actually debate
and reach a position of consensus on how
to regulate so we have a couple of
I think quite positive signs in the
Horizon of course the EU is about to
pass its own AI act it's the first ever
Omnibus piece of legislation dedicated
to AI because things are slow maybe
maybe Canada will be maybe Canada
could could be there faster I'm hoping
Canada gets there this year but we'll
see but the issue of course is that if
we look at the EU it took them four
years to draft this legislation which
happened before the generative AI turn
so we're already behind now if we look
at the US it's radically depressing
because we are so far behind we had the
great benefit briefly of having Dr
Alondra Nelson in the office of Science
and Technology policy who put forward a
potential Bill of Rights for AI but that
is not regulation that doesn't have the
teeth that yahshua was speaking of so
how are we going to get the US which is
such a power center of these companies
to take the regulation as seriously as
it takes the business side I'm I'm with
you and like that's the thing that that
really does keep me up at night so I
want to mention
um a couple of things that I think the
Canadian government seems to be doing
well here
um one is uh similar to what the
European regulation has which is uh the
regulation can be proportional to the
level of risk right so uh
but but but the second one I think
um I mean the tools of the regulation
the second one is something that I find
really nice in the Canadian way of uh
thinking about this which is to create a
principles-based law
and then an Adaptive set of regulations
so it's very difficult for politicians
to change a law and especially because
parties change and whatever but but we
can agree on ethical objectives and that
can go into the law and and then the
regulation can be well much faster maybe
not fast enough but but it's much better
um to to do it this way
um there's also an idea that I find
interesting
um
coming from Jillian hatford in Toronto
where she's thinking that well yeah
governments are too slow to adapt uh to
these kinds of regulatory challenges but
um maybe we could have independent third
parties that are competing
to provide regulations and that are like
judged in terms of well how well we
succeed to to to protect the public in
particular areas with the companies that
they're working with
um I think it's it's an interesting uh
question because there are issues with
governments being to have too much
inertia too slow
um and bureaucratic on how do we keep
Pace with the the the you know the speed
of uh of the markets
I'll be honest though I I worry that the
only solution to regulation is to turn
it into a market a competitive market I
think part of the problem is in fact
market dynamics yeah but that's what
she's proposing exactly so I have real
concerns about oh I mean I think I think
this is precisely what we want to avoid
is applying a market logic to everything
that we do all the way through to our
governance and Regulatory structures I I
completely understand that the need to
think about how do we have more flexible
and adaptive approaches but I do think
that there is a virtue and innovate I
mean I think her point is that we need
to innovate in how we regulate and I
completely agree but I also want to
protect the value of what you have
written about in in terms of slow
science sure slow regulation has also
been beneficial if we make the wrong
regulations quickly very bad things can
happen so how do we think about these
questions around public utility public
ownership and potentially a form of both
National and international governance
that prioritizes transparency
auditability and again testing the
impacts of these systems and if those
impacts are negative then frankly we
have to have accountability as well so
one of the key words you you mentioned
that I think can help us with that
mismatch that we're talking about
is transparency so it's hard for the
religious player to anticipate bad
things that can happen
but if if we you know put in that
transparency these you know Audits and
so on
um the need for companies to document in
detail what they're doing
um then and put the tools so that okay
uh these people represent people
um the governments and and so on I can
raise Flags
and and when something maybe was Kept
Secret suddenly make it public because
companies don't want to have you know
Bad Things become public so I think
there may be ways to write regulation
and such a way that uh companies will
have a very strong incentive to avoid
you know not thinking about the bad
things that can happen
I completely agree and I think what
you're pointing to as well is a research
challenge that we actually need social
scientists and humanists researching
what are good regulatory structures what
a good regulatory mechanisms and what
are the ways in which we can hold
companies accountable if we're going to
continue in this way where shareholder
motivations are really driving the
creation of so many systems how can we
have those forms of accountability that
are really reliable that we can point to
and expect that they can prevent these
harms I think I think this is the
question that for both of us we have
really
thought about for the last few years
which is so much money goes into the
technical side of thinking about these
infrastructures and so little investment
has gone into these much more Broad
Social scientific and humanistic
questions around regulation around
management and around accountability and
transparency and I think that's the big
challenge facing us now is to try and re
readdress that balance I would go even
further as you know
uh if I have time
um
so I think that we need to invest much
more in social sciences and Humanities
to help us
really
rethink
our societies
um
at the level you know of each country
but globally as well
and
um I think it's necessary because of
what I was talking about before this
misalignment which becomes becomes more
and more of a problem as the tools we're
building become more powerful and
anybody can just like
exploded in our face
um so for example the kind of
competition that we're currently seeing
between companies
um in a potentially a kind of Race To
The Bottom in terms of
carefulness and ethics
um is is an indication of how bad things
can be in in a few years when these
tools could be doing much more damage
and for me it's questioning I think we
should be questioning and asking are
there other political and economic
models that we could think of explore as
alternatives to
um to what we have now I mean we tend to
think that what you know our current
system is okay and you know it has
problems but we don't even often think
about is there like something really
much better or actually it's not even
much better I think if we don't
really
do these things I'm not sure that
humanity and civilization as we know it
will be there in 50 years and it's not
just AI you know we have climate crises
we have all kinds of very large-scale
crises even the pandemics
where I don't think that our
economic and political organization is
appropriate
and there is not right now a lot of
willingness to consider alternatives but
we should and we should invest in the
serious
research about what are our options how
do we build a different world do we have
examples of ways of humans to work
together that would be less prone to the
sort of uh
dangers that we're talking about
it's almost like you're saying AI among
other things is provoking this new world
order yes and now is the time for you
know you have a bunch of people to sit
around the table and start doing this
design and co-creation of this new world
order or it's just going to happen it's
going to blowing up it's just gonna
happen to us yeah and I loved your
invitation around actually like
structuring research around the
governance I think that this book was
part of that and if yahshua agrees I
think we should create a space for that
at Mila it's such a part of our DNA and
we'll figure out what that means but I I
appreciate the need to say okay we need
to invest as much on all of these
questions and on the development of the
technology itself we're going to open it
up to all of your questions and about a
minute or two how is that going to work
is there a mic that's gonna
okay so we're gonna you just get up and
someone will come to you with a mic wait
for the mic tester question okay one
last prompt for the two of you before we
open it up so we talked about government
and Global coordination meanwhile
um any words of wisdom for us as people
humble servants of society researchers
what should any of us walk away with
what should we be thinking about
well first of all I'm excited that
you're here to think about this with us
this is clearly the biggest challenge
that we could be facing right now and I
and I find it incredibly heartening that
Joshua and I through very different
Paths of research have come to exactly
the same place which is to say that we
now need to emphasize a much bigger
project than thinking about technical
infrastructures we need to think about
what kind of world do we want to live in
and how do we architect that because
right now those those decisions around
architecting power are not being made by
us actually they're being made by an
extremely small number of not elected
officials who are actually creating
systems that could be very general
purpose and could have extraordinary
far-reaching effects some of which could
be quite harmful some of which could be
beneficial but the benefits and the
risks there are not things that we are
currently in the conversation with so
how do we shift that and how do we start
to see the imbrication or the
interweaving of Technology labor and the
environment as things we have to think
about together to keep those three
together in mind because we they are
always profoundly interlaced and that's
to me what we're giving to you today I
think is a democratic challenge how do
we form this into a bigger public
conversation and into real social change
that would be my provocation
you said it almost all but I I wanna I
wanna emphasize one of the words you
said democracy I think it's all about
democracy so in our discussion we talked
about concentration of power powerful
tools lead to constitutional power and
that's why we need to change the system
in small ways in eventually bigger ways
to make sure that we preserve that
beautiful thing
um that is democracy but there is also
not just Powers responded there's
another value that's very dear to me
and that is at the heart of the
scientific community that I think we
need to really put more center stage and
that is proof
that is really about like uh
um a culture that values truth
um because ultimately that's what makes
democracy possible uh information needs
to be accessible
um and the last thing I want to mention
is
it may seem a little bit kind of oh
overwhelming uh like what you know any
of us what can we do right but I think
it we can reflect on what's happened
with the climate crisis
a lot of people feel
helpless like what can I do I'm a small
like Citizen and all these powerful
people or
uh doing things I may disagree with but
um
it's because a lot of people think that
a problem is important that things move
so we all have a possibility of being
part of making a better world
thank you
all right questions
from all of you you will not have this
opportunity often
so for those who have question you can
go
you can follow Cal and there'll be a
line we have something about
15 minutes for the question period so
try to make your
question
quite short and not too tree a sighted
question just a one-sided question
please
thanks thank you so much for a great
question
or great discussion but I do have a
question there and Kate this is for you
you said that in a way innovate how we
regulate and the interesting thing is
that if we look at the previous crisis
like democracy using democracy for
climate has obviously not worked in
terms of how fast we agreed on the Paris
agreement it took 12 years between the
un's foundation until we had the
international Atomic agency of uh Air
energy agency so how do you think that
will work and isn't the approach that
open AI is taking Now by closing their
research a way to try to
innovate the regulate the regulatory
space because they're closing down not
making it publicly available not helping
others in adopting this Technologies
isn't that a way to you know
that's a fantastic question and let me
say
that one of the things that worries me
most about open ai's approach is that
Sam Altman and others have said we need
regulation it is urgent that we have
regulation and they're not giving us the
means to know how to regulate a system
by closing it down and making it
completely opaque to Regulators so you
can't have your cake and eat it too if
you actually want both science to build
on your work if you want Regulators to
create good regulatory structures you
need more openness you need more
transparency so I think one of the first
questions we have to face from a
regulatory perspective is how can you
ensure at least some culture of
transparency because I'm seeing the same
thing that you're seeing which is a
rapid closing down of information
at the same time as you're seeing a
rapid concentration of power
and that should be a deep concern to all
of us and I think one of the things that
hopefully everybody in this room today
is hearing from both the OSHA and I is a
really clear Clarion call for Rapid
change now that this is urgent and this
is extremely serious because what you
just described is an inherently
anti-democratic tenancy thanks
hi there Martin Patrick I'm a journalist
with the logic yeah
um you know I was thinking about your
example of the player piano and the
Copyright Act it was about 15-year
window in there uh and using that as
sort of like as a precedent for what can
happen but we have a massive precedent
already
um with with Facebook or any other big
tech company like that uh you know uh
uh 15 years ago Facebook started and I'm
in a room full of researchers right now
I've spoken to countless researchers who
say we try and try and try to get data
it's it's opaque we never get anything
um uh 15 years on Facebook Remains the
uh picture opacity uh when it comes to
being able to look at the building
blocks of this stuff which is data so I
guess if it hasn't worked with Facebook
if it hasn't worked with big Tech why on
Earth would it work with AI if we're
shoveling it into Facebook or a chatbot
there's to me there doesn't seem to be
much difference
well well let's talk about the real
politic of what happened with Facebook
you're absolutely right that we saw
absolute disasters like Cambridge
analytica before we saw any real
regulatory conversation but there has
been an important shift in DC have a
look at how much money tech companies
are spending on lobbyists to shift and
prevent real regulation from happening
that is a profound issue that has I
think in in many cases slowed down any
real regulatory will in DC and so if
we're going to see any change at this
time around if I'm going to have if I'm
going to give you an optimistic
perspective here it's that what we're
seeing now at AI is so general purpose
it's not a social network that you can
choose to join or leave these are tools
that will affect you no matter if you
choose to participate them or not and I
think that presents our Regulators with
a far higher degree of responsibility
for their constituents but where we
still face this very real problem of an
enormous amount of money in DC there to
prevent real regulation so what that
gets down to is pressure from us from
citizens on our politicians to say we
have to see action here because that's
the only way we're going to see change
which is not to say I'm being a
Pollyanna here I think it's extremely
difficult but if we're going to see
these tools applied simultaneously to
every industry you can think of to
hospitals to schools to every White
Collar office then there is a very large
population of people who should be
having a scientists
I just want to add a
yes in the past
uh
Civil Society has been trying to push
things to to improve uh some of the
issues you've been talking about
and because it was too slow or it didn't
work doesn't mean that we shouldn't keep
trying and and working hard towards
those goals just have to that's the only
thing we can do
thanks
so high is
trying to find a way to ask this
question uh it's basically the at the
hearts we're talking about putting
pressure on our politicians to change
things but what about the people who
work at these companies and in
particular you work at Microsoft
research major investor of open AI I
don't want to single with Microsoft
there's also other big companies
what can these people do you are also
let's assume but these people are privy
to some of the things that they're
saying like how can we shift the power
like that's the question not easy
question I I can say a few words
um I have lots of friends working in
these companies
and
um
I think most of these people want to do
good
so
um we need to
nourish that kind of culture
um
one thing we can do here for example in
Academia is
educate our grad students who will be
the next you know working force in those
companies working on AI
to care about social values to care
about social impact
care about Society
so that when they will be hired their
voice will be at least something to
contend with of course it's not enough
we need to change
the way governments are are dealing with
these but
um it's important to keep in mind that
vast majority of people and companies
are just
trying to do their best in end in you
know in a good human way but they're
part of a system of profit maximization
and the companies that are not
sufficiently pushing for profit
maximization
bill
um so there's like a survival of the
most profitable
um and we shouldn't
put the orders on those people working
in those companies it's really the
responsibility of governments to put the
Right Guard brands
I would I would absolutely agree with
that and I would add to it that one of
the things that has actually produced
real change in the last few years has
been workers inside tech companies we
have seen an enormous worker movement to
prevent the use of AI in weapons work
inside Google and multiple other
companies we've seen Tech workers
actually unionize for the first time and
we've also seen a few people bravely
speak out when they see things happening
inside their companies that are
concerning them and so I would say that
they're the people you should be really
careful to tune in and listen because
when those people are ringing alarms
something very serious that's happening
um thank you for the debate
um I have this question of
so you're talking about slow science and
slow regulations
um I'm just afraid that like we are
going to face a disaster
uh similar what to happen to nuclear
right
um and actually I truly believe that we
are actually experiencing that disaster
gradually and you're like kind of like a
frogs in this boiling water and you're
not really seeing what is happening to
our lives and AI is affecting people's
lives right
um what we should do because some of the
questions that I have in my mind is that
like regulations transparency yes I
think like it's not just the open AI I
think the technology was in a in a in a
in a stage as if it's not open AI it's
going to be company X right I don't
think it's surprising to see this kind
of Technologies coming out right but
what is strange to me is that we are way
way behind actually knowing what is the
harm so even if they are transparent if
they we know what is the model what is
the data how we can measure the harm we
don't know it I think like because I'm
working on this topic myself this is
still an earlier stage of recognizing
what are the harms of this model so I
just to ask you like what do you think
like what we should do as an action
right so me as a researcher working on
this topic like what I should do uh to
make sure that it's not happening and it
is a disaster that's happening like what
I'm saying is that like I should do it
faster right
thank you
this is a this is a really important
question too and I guess I would say two
things I think your diagnosis is correct
that we're seeing a diffuse
that of Slow Rolling crises for now and
that could change as these systems
quickly start to filter into so many
Industries at the same time
but you're asking this question around
harms that I think is really interesting
um and I want to point to something that
I think openaid idea that was really
good uh in their recent report was that
they had what they call a system card
and that system card is building on work
that timnit and I and other colleagues
did with our work on data sheets for
data sets and then Mega Mitchell and
others did with model cards for model
reporting that we're now seeing system
cards and and what I see in that system
card if you read it very closely
it outlines several very real risks that
open AI sees and does not have
mitigations for including that chat Bots
can concretize ideologies and ideas that
we will have no way of actually
remedying and then it says something
very interesting after outlining
disinformation harms privacy harms
discrimination harms ideological harms
it then says all of these harms are the
way that AI will go unless we put in
very clear ways of stopping it and what
we haven't done is put in those ways of
stopping it yet so I think what we're
hearing even from inside the house so
the call is coming from inside the
building now at open AI people are
telling us that they're seeing these
risks and yet we do not have the
mitigations yet so that is a very clear
challenge to everybody in this room how
do we address that challenge in our work
just want to add I think there are both
uh technical efforts that can be made to
try to address some of these challenges
but also regarding the urgency and so on
um it's part of the conversation we're
having and all you know a lot of the
previous questions and I would like to
mention here the role of the media
because if governments are not going to
do anything if they don't feel the
pressure from the people and the media
being their voice
if there is not enough concern in the
population about these questions
nothing's going to happen or it's going
to be extremely slow
so those conversations we're having
today are very important for that
thanks for your work on this
um
[Music]
let's see
for example
um
[Music]
foreign
attention
is a problem is
he developed
foreign
[Music]
so two questions more I'm sorry for the
people on the line uh we're running late
a little bit
so very sorry for that
good morning
associate member here at Mila so you
talked about the six AI companies that
hold the keys to generative AIA I'd like
to bring to the conversation
uh what I think was an important shift
in personal Computing OS landscape
towards digital Freedom made by Linux
and open source software
are you aware of Open Source Community
Driven efforts that are trying to match
the private Investments how far behind
are they is data holding them back is it
possible that regulation EG who owns
data could hurt rather than help such
Community efforts for becoming
mainstream and how could we ensure such
efforts flourish in a regulatory context
uh maybe I'm going to say a few words
about this uh yes there are Community
efforts
um
but they don't have enough
Capital to bring things to the scale
that we're seeing with say open AI
and I think it is therefore extremely
important that governments understand
that you know collectively we need to
invest in alternatives
to make sure that power is less
concentrated to make sure also that we
make AI work for the benefits of society
um
at the same time we have to be careful
but I think it's going to be
careful for the same reasons the openai
are saying that they're not like making
their code available uh you want to make
sure those tools
are used in a controlled way I think
there are ways to do all that
um
but but I don't think governments have
yet understood that they need to invest
like the kind of capital that that
companies are currently investing to
build Tools in in sort of a
Community Spirits
and if I may um I just noticed that the
the two people who sat down were both
women could I invite you back up just
because of the for the issues of
diversity because it's something that we
really take very seriously
um if each of you could just say your
question quickly all three of you I
don't want to I don't want to shut you
down sir as well please stay but um if
each of you just say your question
quickly the two of us can choose which
ones we can respond to with our last few
minutes
I really appreciate that thank you
um so my question is there was a lot of
mention about how extractive artificial
intelligence is and some of the risks
that it poses to important institutions
like our democracy but my question is
do you see potential of AI being
restorative in any ways whether that's
through Universal basic income or other
opportunities that I might present
throughout that value chain that uh Kate
you've done so much research on thank
you
hi thank you uh so my question Builds on
Joshua's point about our systems being
like our governance systems being not
fit for purpose so
um specifically like in a globalized
context and uh looking at uh companies
big Tech in particular
from the lens of not being just an
entity to regulate but also an entity
that is providing and functions that are
historically been given by governance
and
um in a certain way replacing governance
um so how can we look at big tag
um maybe from the same lens that you
know founding fathers of many Democratic
um countries looked at to put some
guarantees about the power of these
companies the same way like a a country
in the past like could still abuse power
um so that's my first question my second
question is more building on
inter-government like intergovernmental
um efforts so and the cooperation so
there are many forums now from uh you
know the oecd from Apec from TTC from
also the global partnership on AI where
do you see maybe the most using links
and where like where where do we need
more work to improve cooperation thank
you
I'm going to say very quickly a few
words about uh first question from
Allison
um
I think that you're putting your finger
in something really important which is
especially if we have Investments like
coming from governments like really
targeted at the well-being of everyone
they can be specifically targeted at
innovations that will help to distribute
power more so a a very obvious example
is AI that can help democratize
education and Justice by the way
and I mean if if done right I think that
there's a huge potential here
um to to bring billions of people uh out
of the you know illiteracy that they're
in using those tools and by the way I do
think that humans are essential in
education but that's a longer
conversation
and I'll address the first part of your
second question uh which is this idea of
the fact that we're starting to see the
private sector and particularly this
very small group of technology companies
really taking on the role that was once
given to governments and that's not an
accident that is a very clear
encroachment on particular sorts of
services that were once understood to be
publicly owned and it's precisely that
type of enclosure as it was
traditionally called from the sort of
1500s onwards in the UK where we started
to see sort of the enclosure of public
lands for private ownership and wealth
that we've now seen in in the public
sector in public sector services and
that points exactly not to me to oh
let's just give it to the to the private
sector but the opposite which is to say
when the private sector is saying these
are public goods but we're going to
capitalize on them the public has the
opportunity to say which one of those
things should now remain in public hands
where are these infrastructures actually
suitable for nationalization for
actually
re-enriching the public so I think we
can actually take a much more radical
line on understanding that shift that
you absolutely widely pointed to and I
think to the second question what we are
starting to see at the international
level of governance is still quite
nascent
um and the problem that I'm seeing with
some of the organizations you mentioned
such as the global partnership it's a
it's a fantastic idea but it doesn't
have the force of Regulation so we're at
a moment in history where International
regulatory bodies like the UN are losing
respect and strength so one of the
things we need to do is strengthen those
muscles to say that International
governance is what is going to be
essential for both the climate crisis
and for governing AI thanks for the
question
so when we publish an adverted an
updated version of this book it's going
to be a whole day event because it feels
cruel to stop this conversation at this
stage
thank you to each and every one of you
for making the time this is not
something one or two or three world
leaders can carry it's something we must
all carry I think that message was clear
merci thank you
this is the result of your vision and
your conviction and you could have quit
a thousand times along the way and you
didn't the only reason we're here
Yeshua you're an inspiration and such a
privilege to have as a colleague your
fire lights flames and all of us and we
will humbly do our best to use
everything you've created here at Mila
to honor this Vision you have
and Kate you are so courageous and I'm
so grateful for you just saying it as it
is and this conversation needs more of
us going to that length and just saying
it and calling it and asking for
clarification and asking for change so
thank you thank you so much
yes Valerie so you can have coffees uh
and teas over there you have croissant I
will ask Joshua Kate good news Benjamin
and Valerie to go over the wall for an
official picture and after Benjamin and
Joshua will be available for Medias
thank you to everybody